what's the biggest takeaway from the
all-star weekend Reggie is painful okay
it went on too long it wasn't funny and
then I said this is painful and you go
no it's Hollywood I say no it's hardwood
a Turner employee we are not responsible
for we're only responsible for the game
so I'm not blaming you I'm not blame the
Kevin Hart thing that's all the NBA and
NBA entertainment Fergie that's all the
NBA
Pharrell at halftime we're only
responsible for the game which is on our
network so you know you're acting like
we put no it was just an observation
that I knew that you were observing if
if somebody didn't see it how would you
describe the pregame personally I loved
Kevin Hart introduction of the all-stars
it was off that was funny because that
was he was in his element and they were
the reason why it wasn't so funny is
because a lot of his jokes were inside
jokes because the players were cracking
up because he knows all of them and he
was kind of clowning them but people in
the audience or watching at home had no
idea because most of the jokes were
inside jokes for the players how about
some outside jokes that I could have
laughed at the inside ones I didn't
laugh at and I will say this being in
front of Fergie and listening to it it
wasn't as bad as people at home I'm sure
we're making it out to be
did it have its Marilyn Monroe s feel to
it seemed to John F Kennedy in moments
it did and sound like she was gonna
burst into happy bread yay
[Music]
Yeah right the Danites gave me grief
because I said why was Kevin Hart
crunching down when if he stood straight
up in Donovan Mitchell factory like
that's mirrored it I'm just saying if
he's not at all he said there was no
need for any of them to scrunch down
because he had cleared them by what
three or four feet yeah and it would
have looked better and he said the big
wall Kevin Hart and he never needs to
scrunch anywhere come on okay Dennis
Smith jr. had the best done which one
the through that he went remember you
guys were talking about oh yeah the
reverse Eddy Weaver any change tear and
he can't do anything yes I mean that was
unbelievable it was far better work any
other dunk that Donovan Mitchell had I
thought the one where he did jump over
the Hart family as well as his sister
was pretty good he I just wish they
never would have scrunched now I do and
the Vince Carter it makes you appreciate
number one how high Vince Carter was on
that iconic done 18 years ago and then
when Donovan Mitchell tried to emulate
it it just makes you appreciate the how
beautiful our dunk that was bye-bye
Vince Carter
okay did the new format save the
all-star weekend it did I mean look in
most all-star games not the recent ones
that we've been seen but in years past
they usually started to play mid a third
quarter and all the way into the fourth
quarter and made it a game these guys
actually came out and tried to play
defense there was some full-court traps
there wasn't a lot of it look you're
gonna have your old lady fence
occasionally it's an exhibition game
but for the most part eighty to ninety
percent these guys tried to get after it
and it kind of showed the product was
much better and we saw what kind of
finish we had I mean who would have
thought that would have came down to our
defensive stuff as opposed to someone
trying to score yeah I liked it I liked
that you co-signed on my idea with the
three-point shooting contest I'm
watching you
you and you and Chris Webber at the end
of the Saturday night when Brent berry
said what would you guys add and then
next thing I know Reggie Aloysius Miller
is gone you know what I would do I'd get
like an older guy with a younger guy and
no patience no Jankovic and you and I
went you said oh my god
if I find it what are you gonna give
yeah what do you I want your Bentley oh
the Bentley's gone oh yeah but okay
maybe we kind of cultivated the idea
here thank you and I you know I do great
ideas I mean if I could came up with
like klay Thompson if Ray Allen could
team up with Steph Curry if pages died
octopus could team up with Devin Booker
and do team three-point shooters I love
it I love it that would be often I think
it would be great
here's the other thing the Commissioner
brought up this reseeding or maybe we
just have the best teams you know first
second third and it feels like when he
when he talks about it that it's gonna
happen do you see that it doesn't matter
if you play in the east or the west
you're gonna be seeded by your record
and you know then you just play out the
format after that well you always want
to see the the best 16 teams in the
playoffs my only question mark will be
or how will you regulate the regular
season because right now between the two
conferences I mean will more Western
Conference teams play Eastern Conference
teams or vice versa so how are you gonna
regulate the regular season to build up
pours that you know best 16 teams play
in a balanced a balanced schedule is
really the key for me that if you can
balance in travel not as much it feels
like there's so much time in between
games I'm not as concerned about that as
I am a balanced schedule and if you get
the best 16 teams because every team has
their own play knows you mentioned
there's no back to backs sometimes
there's two or three games in between
between games so I'm not worried about
travel but
to me how are you going to do the
regular season because there are some
Western Conference powerhouses and
there's some you know you've got a
ladder in Brooklyn what do you do with
those teams I mean because the Eastern
Conference team plays in four or five
times whereas Western Conference teams
only plays them twice yeah talking to
Reggie Miller Reggie has got clippers
and the Warriors coming up Thursday
night what's it say about the league the
Clippers and warriors don't have a
representative in the all-star game I
mean with porzingis going down for New
York it was very difficult I mean you
need major market players to be in a
showcase game I can't remember the last
time that the Lakers are gone this long
without having a player in the showcase
you know times may be changing but they
got to get better you get better you'll
be in there I thought Lou Williams
should have been in all-star IV was
having an all-star season yeah but they
didn't think so let me see what else do
I have for you what did you was this a
big deal about the Fox News host Laura
Ingraham telling LeBron just shut up and
dribble was that a big topic of
conversation at all over the weekend it
was and I'm glad LeBron addressed that
and I'm glad he was out of it by coming
up and saying no I will not
just shut up in drivel because LeBron
arguably is the most powerful person not
only in the NBA maybe in sports in
professional sports in America certainly
and his voice resonates and he does so
much look we can criticize him all he
wants about wanting to be the goat and
is he close to Michael Jordan or Kareem
or whatever that's our job X's and O's
but what he does away from the court and
in the community and what he has done
for so many young african-american kids
being able to go to school that normally
would not be able to you've got to look
at the Mane's of resume and that's why I
hope he never ever listens to people by
telling them he should just be an
athlete and just go play sports because
he is touching people's lives so what
she did was make his platform even
bigger
and kind of made her look well it's Fox
News you know there's a base for that
there's you know obviously it riled up
her base and around up LeBron James and
everyone else's basic but just the
beauty of it and you know I said this on
the air LeBron shouldn't get upset and
shouldn't try to you know go back at her
because it's freedom of speech now the
same way you're able to say what you
want about the president she's saying
the same thing about you
hey like our former first lady say when
they go low we go high you know it's
validating his platform and I think
that's why people are circling the
wagons around LeBron James did you rub
elbows with celebrities any that we'd be
impressed by who did you want to meet
who did I want to meet ya or did who did
you mean it was cool having snoop come
by the table double og it was always
nice having snoop come by Kevin Hart
well obviously you didn't like his
opening but it was cool having Kevin
there we tried to give Beyonce of course
we got shut down
why got shut down well clean B didn't
want to come on come on what come on
come on what all we can do with that
yeah I know but I'm just saying come on
come on B let's go
let's talk might come on let's talk we
tried to get Jimmy Kimmel over how about
this what was funny is looking at Jimmy
Kimmel's reaction to Fergie that was
pretty funny because I don't know if he
was submerging or laughing just
enjoyment or like what is he green
draymond greens mouth was open I don't
know if he's a mouth breather or he was
just like
not sure what's going on here on
Thursday well I do the game but I'm
gonna go with mouth-breather okay but
you saw the reaction when we put them on
with the fans were like laughing I don't
know Paulie wants to ask you the poll
question all right Reggie if you were in
the winter or summer olympics not
basketball
would you rather win four silver medals
or one gold medal that's it four silver
medals or one gold uh
and what did I do in those other three
of is I didn't play and you didn't play
right nothing I'm probably gonna go with
four silvers and it's the right answer
I'm probably gonna go with four Silver's
that shows consistency one gold is great
but I was consistent over four events
how about you can lose four NBA Finals
or you can win one and be a fun one
[Laughter]
we're Shaq Shaq and Charles like it it
always devolves into Charles never won a
championship but it felt like you know
with the Kobe and Shaq sit down and then
you guys talked about it afterwards
Charles and Shaq looked like that they
could go do you feel you always look
like that that's what makes our show
beautiful because number one those guys
are unscripted they never tell they
never give them a heads up of where
we're going and Narnians fantastic is
being probably the best traffic cop in
the business but these are two guys that
were competitors once before and they
love to butt heads they're very
opinionated both of them who would you
say they who would you take in a in a
brawl yeah I'm going with Shaq but don't
underestimate the countries the country
strong of Charles Charles is country
strong he is it checks the biggest guy
on the plane yeah that's the biggest man
on the planet so I gotta go with Shaq
but I think Charles uses leverage here
and then he's got I don't know oh okay
okay you got a better scouting report
than I do
yeah yeah reg well being golden state
it's the Clippers against the Warriors
you can tell Lou Williams in person he
should have been an all-star and I
believe I agree with that here's another
thing reg next year when they do the
all-star game and everybody says oh
such-and-such should have been an
all-star in such an I want everybody to
know you have to take somebody off when
you say some razor okay so that's where
you go I'm sorry Al Horford you don't
belong on the all-star team or whoever
it might be everybody can't be an
all-star but it always feels like we
want everybody to be one and then we
don't take anybody off so just let's
just remember that next year okay I
think that was a thinly veiled shot at
Al Horford are you saying Al Horford
should not have been in all-stars this
particular year of course he shouldn't
that's not a veil that's an unveiled reg
Al Horford nice player he shouldn't have
been an all-star okay well who would you
put on in the East instead of Al Horford
the team at there at the time they had
the best record right now Toronto does
but the time the teams were selected
Boston had the second best record in the
whole league I'd have to look at other
guys who were left off in these now the
West is a little bit different because
to me they had more players that easily
could have that were more deserving yeah
but I mean how Horford's al al has been
in five all-star games reg wait he's
been as many all-star games as you I
think you've been in five right I have
reg I have it's not fair yes I would put
in I would have put in Ben Simmons over
Al Horford can argue with that I'll talk
to you next week boom dropped it right
there just dropped it thank you
Thank You Reggie that's a Reggie
Aloysius Miller junior the third he's
got clippers warriors Thursday night
Reggie Miller brought to you by
mercedes-benz drivers seat the Mercedes
driver's seat Mercedes the best or
nothing for more dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]